welcome to update 11 in this update we  have a brand-new highly tactical game  world for you deadlock is based around  capturing and holding seven control  zones to win you need to capture and  hold all zones or eliminate the entire  enemy team we've also introduced the  brand new assault rifle AR 03 this  assault rifle is designed for medium to  long ranges and to counterbalance ACS ng  has been rebalanced for shorter  engagements at the end of the last  update video we hinted us to a new map  that map is stronghold and has been  introduced in both the multiplayer  section and the playground drunk hold  stretches from lush dense forest  vegetation all the way through to a  tight confined urban space and finally  at the top of the main menu we've added  a new tab called tutorials